I'd bet that some of you have never
heard of Yoruba which is stunning
because it's an incredibly important
language maybe just not in your part of
the world it's spoken by somewhere
between 30 and 45 million people and
that number is going to climb rapidly in
the coming decades because of the
massive population growth in West Africa
Yoruba is one of the three main African
languages of Nigeria along with hausa
and IBO the official language of Nigeria
is English and Nigerian pidgin an
english-based Creole is widely spoken
but Yoruba hausa and Igbo are widely
used amongst their respective ethnic
groups as are hundreds of less widely
spoken languages and because of the
large number of Yoruba speaking
immigrants living around the world it's
the most widely spoken African language
outside of Africa obviously I mean
language is native to Africa English
doesn't count here's a sample of what it
sounds like
are you Dubai we do is
mainly spoken in Southwestern Nigeria
including the capital city Lagos though
many languages are now spoken there and
dialects closely related to Yoruba are
spoken in Southeastern Benin and parts
of Togo along with Yoruba proper these
dialects are part of the yodoboid
language group which form part of the
Niger Congo language family yodoboid
includes igala edekiri which splits into
izakiri the ere dialects spoken mainly
in Benin and Togo and Yoruba dialects a
day dialects are sometimes considered
Yoruba dialects as they are very closely
related and their speakers identify as
ethnic Yoruba people Yoruba proper has
many dialects but their standard Yoruba
which serves as the formal and written
form of the language and a bridge
between those dialects Yoruba dialects
and related yoruboid languages are
spoken throughout yodoba land but all
the yoduba people see ileife as the
origin of their civilization during the
Ife Kingdom which was dominant between
the year 1000 and 1420. in the yoluba
tradition ileife is thought to have been
founded by odudua a yoduba king thought
to be divine but Yoruba civilization
didn't consist of just a single Yoruba
political entity there were numerous
city states that spoke Yoruba dialects
or related yoruboid dialects including
Oyo the Oyo Empire surpassed ileife and
became the main Yoruba power from 1600
to around 1800 A.D until internal
conflict led to its downfall and a
century of warfare after its downfall
the British expanded their influence in
the area and established the colony and
protectorate of Nigeria in 1914
incorporating the Yoda bus speaking
areas in the Southwest Standard Yoruba
was put together in the 1850s by Samuel
A Crowther ayuruba Nigerian and the
first Anglican Bishop in West Africa he
published a grammar of standard yoduba
and translated the Bible into it as well
standard Yoruba was based on a number of
dialects but mainly all ya and ibadan
dialects its orthography has gone
through several changes since then it's
written in a latin-based alphabet but it
makes use of a number of accent markings
and diacritics and that brings us to an
important feature of yoduba but first
let's talk about a software tool with
numerous benefits for all of you World
Travelers and language enthusiasts I'm
talking about the sponsor of this video
Atlas VPN for Christmas and New Year's
they have an amazing sale price of just
a dollar seventy a month plus six months
free which you should definitely take
advantage of I use Atlas VPN to view
content online that's exclusive to
certain countries when I want to watch
shows or movies in a different language
I use Atlas VPN to make streaming
services think I'm in a country where
that language spoken giving me access to
more local content you can also use
Atlas VPN to keep your Google searches
and downloads private like if you're
traveling in a country where an invasive
government might be monitoring your
online activity or if you're worried
about big Tech using your data it also
stops illicit ads malware and trackers
and notifies you of attempts to use your
data also a VPN can help you get the
best online prices like the time I saved
hundreds of dollars on a stock music
subscription by using the American
version of the site rather than my local
version I prefer not to be ripped off
thank you very much so Atlas VPN is a
very useful tool all over the world and
it's the best deal all over the world at
only a dollar seventy per month for a
three-year subscription with six months
free on unlimited devices with a 30-day
money-back guarantee but time is running
out so be sure to lock in that low price
by clicking the link in the description
down below
and now back to Features Yoruba has
three tones which are shown in writing
hi with an acute accent low with a grav
accent and middle these days with no
marking though it used to be shown with
a macron for example look at the word
for cat
it has a middle tone then a high tone
then a low tone
the tones are phonemic and changes in
tone result in changes in meaning
Means War is the Yoruba God of iron war
and technology and is the name of a
river another marking you'll notice in
text is a DOT below E O and S it changes
the vowels from close to open a to E and
O to ah it changes the s from
there are three types of syllable in
Yoruba those that consist of a vowel a
consonant plus a vowel or a syllabic
nasal in the example there are two
syllables the first a vowel and the
second a consonant plus a nasal vowel
even though in writing the n M looks
like a separate consonant the
combination of vowel plus n actually
shows a nasal vowel an example of a
syllabic nasal is one form of the
pronoun meaning I which is used in
negative sentences some other
interesting consonants in Yoruba are
Velar labial stops
they have a double articulation at the
lips and at the back of the roof of the
mouth
the letter P in writing represents the
sound there's no simple sound in the
language other notable features the
basic word order of Yoruba is SVO
the sentence means they bought a house
word for word they buy house note that
in speech this is pronounced like
because when a word ending in a vowel is
followed by a word that begins with a
vowel they blend together this SVO order
can change with a focused construction
knee marks the focus
they bought a house or it is they who
bought a house this is still SVO but the
subject is the focus I want is the
emphatic pronoun meaning they and it's
followed by the focus marker
they bought a house or a house is what
they bought this is now osv and the
object is the focus if you notice that
ra has a different tone in this sentence
that's because in its basic form it has
a low tone but before a direct object it
has a mid-tone like in the SVO version
of this sentence a couple of other
things to note about yoruba's grammar it
has no grammatical gender no noun cases
no plural forms and no definite or
indefinite articles this is good news
for people who have no patience for
learning the ins and outs of grammar
verbs are also not conjugated for person
number or gender or tense for that
matter tense and aspect markers are
placed before the verb to indicate time
when it's just the verb stem on its own
for a dynamic verb that indicates simple
past for a state of verb it indicates
present or past
I slept
I'm sleeping or I was sleeping this is
the progress massive or imperfective
aspect note that before the progressive
marker the pronoun Mo becomes Mo with a
low tone is also another example of a
syllabic nasal
I've slept this is the perfective aspect
I've been sleeping the perfect
progressive form
I will sleep in the future tense now
that we've seen some standout features
of Yoruba let's look at some basic
phrases this is one way to give a
general greeting like hello but you can
also use a greeting for the specific
time of day
good morning note that if there's more
than one tone in one syllable then the
vowel is normally written once for each
tone these three A's are all part of a
single syllable but with a high low high
progression
good afternoon
good evening or good night note that e
is honorific and is not used when
speaking to friends colleagues and
people younger than you it's the second
person plural personal pronoun which is
also used for the honorific second
person singular the main word in each
greeting is a contraction of coup a verb
used to Mark greetings plus a noun is
the word for morning is the word for
Midday is the word for evening or night
what's your name informal word for word
it's what Focus marker name your but it
might also be said with contractions
notice that the nasal sound becomes a la
sound when ni contracts to the following
word and the re sound is lost the formal
way to say it is
the second person plural possessive
adjective but also the formal or polite
second person singular urukami Nepal my
name is Paul word for word it's name my
focus marker Paul notice that the noun
and the possessive adjective me function
as one unit as a noun phrase and the
focus marker comes after it another way
to say the sentence is
word for word it's Paul Focus marker
name my in this sentence the focus is on
the name so you could think of it like
Paul is my name or my name is Paul with
stress on the name and when spoken
naturally it might be
because as we saw before neet becomes
Lee you know me do not take my day right
nice to meet you wood for wood it's
insides my Pleasant infinitive marker
meet you in this sentence we see the
phrase which means I'm happy but
literally it's more like my insides are
Pleasant then we see
meaning to meet in which Lati is the
infinitive marker
[Music]
where's the bus station word for word
it's where Focus marker station bus
located
is the interrogative pronoun meaning
where here it's the focus and is marked
with knee interrogative pronouns are
always the focus
means station and
means boss is a verb meaning to be
located at
you have nice shoes word for word you
have shoes that are nice simple
adjectives in Yoruba come directly after
the noun but Dada is actually a
descriptive verb meaning to be nice so
it can't come directly after the noun it
needs this connecting word
is actually a contraction of meaning
that is or that are
my friend gave me these shoes word for
word friend my give me direct object
marker shoe these
means friend and is followed by the
possessive adjective me means give me
but note that the verb is understood in
the past tense in its base form like
this me is the indirect object when
there's an indirect object then the
direct object takes a special marker
means
is a plural demonstrative meaning these
do you speak English word for word yes
no question marker you hear language
English in this sentence we see how to
form a yes or no question in Yoruba you
add the question marker without the
question marker this would be a
statement
you speak English
is actually the verb meaning here but
it's used when saying you're proficient
in a language the word for language is
[Music]
the word for English it comes from the
Portuguese word English
yes I speak English word for word yes I
hear language English
is the word for
yesi no I don't speak English word for
word it's no I not hear language English
is the word for no note that the first
person singular pronoun Mo becomes ing
before the negation marker KO like inco
to express what what you like you can
use the phrase I like
boo I like cats word for word I like cat
to say I don't like it
again notice the negation marker and the
different form of the pronoun
I don't like dogs word for word it's I
don't like dog
to express that you like to do something
it's
for example I like to learn languages
I like infinitive marker learn language
Lati is an infinitive marker but on its
own is also a preposition meaning from
or since means learn and again we see
the word for language however when
expressing that you want to do something
Lati is not used
I want to move
I want to learn Yoruba
after this brief little look into Yoruba
I'm sure you can agree that it looks
like a fun and fascinating language and
one that's not too intimidating at least
in certain ways such as its lack of
grammatical gender now in cases plural
forms and articles the main thing that
might seem intimidating is the tonal
system and the way it's represented with
accent markings in writing but those
accent markings can help you know the
tones of words even when you just see
them in writing and you can remember the
tones visually as well as by sound if
you're a speaker of Yoruba to what
extent do you use the standard language
and to what extent do you use your
dialect how easy is it to communicate
with speakers of different Yoruba
dialects and to other people what's your
impression of Yoruba it's time to say
thank you to all of the special Lang
Focus patreon supporters especially the
ones whose names appear right here on
the screen they are the top tier patreon
supporters so many extra special thanks
go out to them as always be sure to
check out patreon.com langfocus to find
out how you can become a patron and
support content like this another West
African language I've covered as wolof
which is spoken in Senegal and The
Gambia check out my video on wolof I
know you'll be blown away by some of the
language's features